so this is in uh again in an examples
page and if we scroll down there's a
section that demonstrates different
types of outputs and so one of the
outputs is plot output
and this is a really basic example once
again so
um our UI is very similar we have an
input slider and this time we have an
output plot
and it's aimed plot but you know just
for clarity I'll call it my plot just so
that that's not confusing
now for this example we also needed to
import matplotlib and numpy to generate
some random data
so
the code is pretty similar to what we
had before we have this output decorator
and we have a render plot decorator this
time instead of render text and it has
some alt text which will display if you
hover over a plot
and then we have the function that
actually generates the plot
now these first two lines here this is
just some numpy code to Generate random
numbers and then this is a matplotlib
histogram so we just say PLT
dot hist
let me give it the data that we
generated
and for this particular function the
second parameter is how many bins are in
the histogram so that's basically like
how wide each of these bars is
so if I make it five
there's only there's five of these bars
if I make it a hundred
there's a hundred of them
so that's all that it really takes to
um to create a plot in shiny you just
say render.plot and then
uh if you're using matplotlib you can
say plt.hist
I know shiny also currently supports
Seabourn and plotline
and it also supports other plotting
libraries that uh
that work in the browser so for example
um
it supports plotly and Altair and those
are supported via the shiny widgets
package
but I'm not going to go over those right
now but just just so you know those you
to use those you don't use render plot
there's there's a different function for
those and there we'll have examples for
that as well
okay so if we want to plot like an
actual data set instead of just this
fake histogram uh there's a great
example data set in a package called
polymer penguins
and let's import that like this from
Palmer Penguins import load underscore
Penguins okay now
uh well one cool thing that you can do
with shiny live is that I can actually
execute this line of code so I'm on a
Mac so I already hit command to enter
um and it'll execute in the terminal on
a Windows machine or Linux you'd press
control enter but I'll just run it like
that
so this polymer Penguins package is
available it's just available and I uh
and if I run load penguins
down here
um it'll it'll run it in this python
console
and print it out here so so we can see
that there's a this is a data frame it's
got
uh 344 rows and eight columns and it's
got data about uh the about various
penguin specimens that were in the wild
Okay so
let's let's say we want to take this
data set and
um
and make a scatter plot of some of the
measurements that we took of these
penguins
so let's get rid of this all this stuff
here we're going to do this differently
and in fact this time we're also going
to use the Seabourn package for plotting
so let's say import Seaborn as SNS
and then I also think we don't we don't
need an Empire we don't need map
um
all right so this time let's we're going
to do a different kind of plot here so
let's say uh we'll do penguins equals
load penguins
and now we want to make a plot out of
this so uh I actually happen to have
done this already
this is like in the cooking show where
you put
you know you put the pan in one oven and
you take it out of the other one so this
is this is the code here for this plot
and
um let's add a couple other things
[Music]
so in this case I've created I've used
Seabourn to create this uh this plot
object and then
and then I'm going to return that plot
object
previously with matplotlib uh what I did
was I just had it do the plotting
command instead of returning a map
plotlib figure object
and that's another way that you can do
it but in this case I'm gonna have it
return the plot object okay so if I run
this
it's going to take a moment to load a
Seaborn I think
and
there we have our scatter plot and this
is a
scatter plot for the three different
species of penguins so uh
that's that's what's Happening Here Hue
is species and we've also fit these
linear model lines uh or these yeah
these linear model fit lines to each
subset of the data now the slider
doesn't actually do anything right now
so I could take it out or I could figure
out what I want to do with it so let's
say we just want to look at uh
one species at a time so instead of
looking at all of them all at once so
right now we have this slider input that
doesn't actually do anything
so let's get rid of that and let's add
uh something that lets us select a
particular species to look at so let's
say UI dot input
um we can do
how about input select this will give us
a selection box so we can say this is
which species you want to look at
and uh let's say which
is
your favorite
and then we can give it a uh a list of
choices so I'm just going to the next
line you can say
uh
a deli which I hope that's how to
pronounce it Gen 2 and chin strap
okay and then we can put a comma there
and another cool thing about this online
editor is you can just click this button
and it'll reformat the code
in theory
there we go I would expect it to be kind
of wide
the the editor would be kind of wide
okay so that gives us uh we'll rerun
this application and then we can select
a particular
species of penguin and
now again this is not hooked up to
anything it's just it's just we've just
added the UI component so in order to
make this actually work
let's say let's take a subset of this
data so we could say Penguins equals
um
ends
where
we can do it this way
when
species
equals
all right so this is going to take a
subset
for just one species and let's rerun the
sound
so this is just showing us the data for
a deli penguins
we change it and strongest data for Gen
2 penguins and
chin strap
[Music]